mesdames messieurs bon dimanche c'est un
plaisir de vous retrouver au nom de
toute l'équipe des coulisses du pouvoir
je vous souhaite une excellente année
2023 dans deux semaines Paul
Saint-Pierre playmondon se préparera
finalement faire son entrée au Salon
bleu de l'Assemblée nationale malgré une
performance électorale décevante le chef
du PQ jouit depuis quelques mois d'une
énorme visibilité entre autres pour sa
prise de position concernant le serment
au souverain mais avec seulement trois
députés et la place limitée qui lui sera
accordée à l'Assemblée nationale le PQ
pourra-t-il continuer à s'imposer j'ai
posé la question à Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon que j'ai rencontré au quartier
général du Parti québécois à Montréal
[Musique]
performance électorale qui a pas été
aussi bonne que ce que vous auriez
souhaité probablement au début or vous
avez quand même eu beaucoup de
visibilité après ça sur le serment sur
le serment souverain sur les propos
passés de celui qui a été pendant
quelques heures l'entraîneur du FC
Montréal vous avez pris beaucoup de
place dans l'espace public comment on
fait pour que ça dure
bonne question mais dans les faits je
dirais que la campagne électorale ce qui
s'en est suivie c'est beaucoup
d'appréciations et de soutien populaire
notamment dans ce qu'on entend quand on
se promène dans la rue les gens
nous disent de pas lâcher de continuer
moi je me suis engagé à être une
opposition constructive c'est ce que je
vais faire et notre philosophie c'est à
dire que le Parti québécois à la base
c'est un parti authentique c'est un
parti de mission sociale de projet de
société on va continuer à faire ça avec
un trio qui a vraiment du fun c'est à
dire que je m'entends très très bien
avec mes compères on est efficace on a
également une fierté de dire les choses
comme elles le sont donné leur juste aux
gens vous êtes les gens les gens nous
parlent les gens nous disent continuent
qu'est-ce qui est différent dans ce que
les gens vous disent maintenant par
rapport à avant la campagne électorale
mon dieu la différence c'est qu'ils me
connaissent première chose et il y a un
attachement on le voit dans les facteurs
comme les dons qui ont vraiment explosé
ce qui fait qu'on sort de l'année
électorale avec un surplus normalement
parti politique finit avec un déficit
puis on a un beau 4 ans
où on va bâtir quelque chose de très
solide pour 2026 tout en veillant au
grain sur les questions importantes donc
c'est un beau 4 ans devant nous vous
allez reprendre les travaux
parlementaires à la fin du mois de
janvier vous allez être le premier
député québécois à faire son entrée au
Salon bleu sans avoir prêté serment ou
souverain c'est important pour vous ça
fait du bien ça fait du bien de ne pas
être pris à le faire c'est un peu une
métaphore de l'indépendance du Québec
quand j'y pense c'est que quelques
semaines auparavant tout le monde
qualifié ça d'impossible dans les faits
a pris 12 minutes et qui parce qu'il est
facultatif le serment roi d'Angleterre
désormais qui parmi ceux des autres
partis qui ont prêté serment qui va
vraiment insister pour prêter serment la
prochaine fois personne
premier député pour avoir prêté serment
vous êtes quand même que trois députés
c'est un petit groupe parlementaire
votre portée ensemble et limiter vos
ressources sont limitées aussi comment
vous envisagez ça comment comment le PQ
peut-il tirer son épingle du jeu
adéquatement dans des circonstances
comme celle-là la date c'est pas mal ça
qu'on fait regardez le début du mois de
janvier regardez comment on travaille
j'ai l'impression d'être un trio de
hockey où est-ce que je connais très
très bien mais mes deux compagnons de
trio donc quand on fait des passes on
sait où est-ce que l'autre et sans
regarder il y a comme une chimie donc je
pense qu'on va être très pertinent et
très audible et les sondages
encourageants aussi nous donne cette
légitimité là parce qu'on est le
deuxième partie particulièrement chez
les francophones on est très on a un
réel soutien dans la population donc je
pense qu'il y aura également de l'écoute
pour on va prendre nos responsabilités
c'est à dire veiller à des décisions en
fonction de l'intérêt public protéger
notre monde comme disait Jacques Parisot
protéger son monde en terme de priorité
en chambre ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire plusieurs sujets évidemment
le français vous vous souviendrez que
monsieur Legault avait pris l'engagement
dans la journée suivant le scrutin de me
rencontrer pour discuter de langue
française j'ai pas eu de nouvelles et là
il y aurait on aura une rencontre lundi
qui devrait porter sur les barrages
électriques parce que Monsieur
du français parce que la situation ne va
pas en s'améliorant et soulève plusieurs
interrogations quand à la suite des
choses les changements climatiques parce
que faire des barrages électriques ce
n'est pas une mesure d'adaptation de
notre économie à la réalité des
changements climatiques donc je vous
permets
dans une certaine mesure mais on peut
pas résumer et limiter la question des
changements climatiques au fait de
construire des barrages surtout si
l'intention en fait c'est de vendre pas
cher
arabais dans des projets très
énergivores notre ressource a une grande
entreprise multinationale donc il y a
une question de vision qui est pas
claire et le départ de sophie Brochu qui
avait exprimé son désaccord avec
monsieur faitgaben qui avait exprimé une
volonté ferme envers l'environnement
mais nous fait faire en sorte qu'on
demande notamment que les oppositions
soient consultées pour la suite
d'Hydro-Québec parce que sinon ça
soulève de véritables questions sur les
orientations là pour la suite des choses
deux éléments sur lesquels je vais
revenir là-dedans la question des
barrages vous êtes contre l'idée vous
dans votre tête on n'a pas besoin de
continuer à construire ou on devrait pas
continuer à construire les barrages au
Québec on peut construire des barrages
mais normalement c'est que ça découle
d'une réflexion sur nos besoins
énergétiques sur la raison de la
construction de ces barrages-là puis si
le plan
c'est essentiellement de miser sur des
projets très énergivors et pendant ce
temps-là il y a pas d'adaptation au
changement climatique il y a pas de
mesure structurantes pour avoir une
économie concurrentielle innovante pour
la suite des choses mais on passe à côté
de l'essentiel donc moi j'ai a priori si
la construction de barrage est fondée
sur une réflexion plus des études
sérieuses discutons-en mais si c'est
comme pour le troisième lien puis qu'on
va jamais les études au soutien de tout
ça puis que c'est comme une impulsion
difficile à expliquer
je pense qu'on doit se poser des
questions plus ramener à l'ordre du jour
la question de l'environnement puis la
question du modèle économique qui
véritablement nous enrichira qui va
enrichir les Québécoises de les
Québécois parce que la marge de profit
d'une multinationale est pas
nécessairement garante de l'argent que
nous on va faire comme québécois la
question de Sophie qui a annoncé que la
quitter en avril qui dit que ça a rien à
voir avec les politiques du gouvernement
c'est pas de mésentente avec le
gouvernement c'est pas une mésentente
avec monsieur Legault avec Monsieur fils
Gabin vous en pensez quoi mais ce que je
sais de la part des journalistes c'est
que monsieur faitgaben a toujours
favorisé des projets énergivores au
profit de la grande entreprise et que
Sophie brochet avait un désaccord sur le
plan environnemental et ça ça a été
documenté par des journalistes c'est un
fait qui a été rapporté donc dans ce
contexte là
on a des inquiétudes quant à la
nomination de du ou de la successeur de
ce fruit Brochu parce qu'on voudrait pas
avoir quelqu'un qui est pas là au mérite
de ses compétences mais bien on mérite
des intérêts partisans de la CAQ
rappelons que la CAQ a déjà mis de côté
la Régie de l'énergie pour ce qui dit au
Québec là mis de côté le processus de
détermination des hausses pour le rendre
complètement arbitraire au gré de la
volonté du politique il y a un moment
donné nous institutions nos sociétés
d'État doivent fonctionner avec les gens
les plus compétents possibles en
fonction de l'intérêt de la canne vous
avez indiqué que vous aimeriez que les
parties d'opposition et leur mot à dire
là-dessus à quel point ça fait
différents après c'est à dire que si au
moins deux parties de position se
mettent d'accord avec la sélection de la
nomination ça veut dire que vraiment
indépendamment de nos orientations
politiques on reconnaît la compétence
l'expertise de la personne en charge de
gérer Hydro-Québec rappelons
qu'Hydro-Québec sur le plan économique
comme environnemental et social c'est
une institution très importante et dont
très fier au Québec est-ce que ce genre
de processus d'approbation là devrait
être utilisé selon vous ailleurs pour
d'autres postes oui parce que avec 90
députés la cape en ce moment peut
essentiellement même pour les
nominations aux deux tiers faire ce
qu'elle veut sur une base purement
politique purement partisanale et si on
veut maintenir la qualité de nos
institutions nos sociétés d'État des
nominations il va falloir une ouverture
du côté de la CAQ de collaborer avec les
oppositions pour qu'on se mette d'accord
dans l'intérêt du Québec et non pas dans
l'intérêt politique d'une formation
politique qui est au pouvoir c'est
fondamental comme différence et ça pour
moi c'est un point qui est très
important
merci beaucoup